نشر المحقق الخاص الامريكي جاكس ميث النص
الكامل للاتهامات الموجهه للرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب واعتبر ان خلق
القوانين يعرض امن البلاد
وتم توجيهها الى دونالد ترامب تتعلق بجنح
خرق قوانين الامن القومي والتعاون مع
اخرين في عرقله العداله
وتشمل الاتهامات الموجهه الى ترامب
الاحتفاظ بوفائق مصنفه سريه وعاليه
الحساسيه بالاضافه الى نقلها واخفائها عن
رجال القانون وكشف مضمونها لاشخاص غير
مرخص لهم بذلك كما تشمل التهم عرقله عمل
لرجال القانون والادلاء بتصريحات كاذبه
والتعاون مع الاخرين لعرقله عمل رجال
القانون والادلاء بتصريحات كاذبه وقد حصل
المحققون على تسجيلات من صحفيين تثبت ان
ترامب عرض عليهم الوثائق السريه كما حصل
المحققون على نصوص رسائل هاتفيه تبادلها
ترامب مع عاملين في مارالاجو يتحدث فيها
عن نقل الوثائق او اخفائها
اعتبر ترامب منذ الاعلان عن توجيه التهم
له انه بريء عن ابن
في المقابل اعتبر محامي ترامب قبل ان
يستقيل ان لا اساس لهذه الاتهامات
انه جريمه ولا اعتقد ان هناك اي اساسا
وفقا لقانون السلطات الرئيسيه ومنذ
الاعلان عن الاتهامات وقفت زعامات الحزب
الجمهوري الى جانب ترامب واعتبرت ان اداره
الرئيس الحالي جوزيف بايدن تستغل وزاره
العدل ضدها ترشيحه الجمهوري
نلتقي اليوم في نيوهامشر وهو يوم حزين
ياتي بعدما واجه رئيس سابق للولايات
المتحده اتهامات غير مسبوقه من قبل وزاره
عدل يديرها الرئيس الحالي الرئيس الامريكي
نفى من جهته الاتصال بوزاره العدل
وتوجيهها الاتهام الى ترامب
لن اتحدث اليهم ابدا ولن افعل ذلك
ستتم اجراءات ما قبل المحاكمه في فلوريا
الامريكيه حيث يقيم الرئيس السابق ويعتبر
خبراء القانون انها قضيه على قدر عال من
الجديه والخطوره
انها قضيه جديه بدون شك ومحاكمه خطيره يجب
النظر اليها بصرف النظر عن الاطار السياسي
ستاخذ هذه القضيه الكثير من وقت
الامريكيين خلال الاسابيع والاشهور
المقبله وتتزامن مع الانتخابات الرئاسيه
حيث يتقدم ترامب على منافسيه الجمهوريين
واحيانا على الرئيس الحالي والمرشح
الديمقراطيم العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات